If appropriate question, are you willing to discuss treatment of your own cancer after
it's spread to the colon? Did you have an operation to remove it or does all it be a treatment
protocol? And what was your thought process? So I did discover my cancer and tell it was
metastasized to my colon. So I did I have an operation? No. There is an operative procedure
for my type of cancer, but it is holy grotesque and it does not work. So that was out of the
question. There is a chemotherapy procedure for my type of cancer, but it was by their
own admission horrible statistics. So it was really easy for me to say forget that.
So no, I didn't do any medical care and do any standards of care. Now again, that doesn't
mean I'm against standards of care. My cancer showed great results with chemotherapy.
I would have at least considered it. I did it did not consider it because it just statistically
was not viable option. So I did the rifled in my nutritional protocol was I did black
sand blood road. I did involve a mute. I did multiple different supplements. Stayed away
from eating a lot of red meat. I didn't eat any dairy products. And so that was my protocol.
I talk about it multiple different areas.